So today we're going to continue our
discussion about uh reachability and
then we move on to the next topic which
is that of model predictive control. So
as you remember from last time we
discussed how a particularly useful
application of uh continuous time closed
loop optimal control is represented by
uh reachability theory that essentially
involves computing reachable sets
through the lens of the habakobi is
equation. So we discussed last time what
reachable sets are and what they
represent. Depending on the
interpretation for the target set we
have two main instanc concept of a
reachable set namely a vodan set and
reach sets. So what we're going to do
today is based on these definitions see
how we can apply the HTOI is equation to
compute these mathematical objects and
then I will discuss how once you have
computed these objects you could use
those in a control pipeline
any questions so just as a reminder we
defined um an
uh avoidance set which is is a
particular instantiation of a backward
reachable set as the set of states at
time t satisfying the following
definition. A stand for avoidance.
This is the set of states for which
there exist a disturbance such that for
all possible control the system enters
the target set at time t equal zero. And
of course once you have completed this
set you want to make sure that you start
outside of this set to guarantee safety.
For uh the opposite the reachable set is
actually the set of desirable states and
is defined as the set set of states at
time t such that for all disturbances
there is a control such that the system
enters target set at time t equals z. So
in this case you would like to start
within the set so that no matter what
natural throws at you you know that
there is a control I mean the optimal
control that will still allow you to
fulfill your control objectives. So this
naturally become a constraints in your
trajectory optimization problem. You
want to ensure that in the case of an
avoidance set you stay your trajectory
stays outside of that set. In the case
of a uh rich uh set you want to make
sure that you know your initial
condition is within that set.
The other question is how do we compute
these sets.
So the point is that you can use the
Hamilton Yakobic E is equation to
compute these sets in a very procedural
uh way. Specifically as we will see the
computation of the backward reachable
sets both in the avoidance case and the
reach case entails solving a
differential game where the outcome is
boo. What does it mean a differential
game from last time differential game
means that there are two players we are
player one we use the controls at our
disposal in order to either avoid a
target set or reach a target set. And
then there's player two nature that
through a disturbance control is trying
to thwart our attempt to fulfill our
control objectives.
Now the question is at the level of a
two-player structure should be quite
intuitive that actually the hamobi is
formalism is well set up to address
these problems. The question though, how
do we instantiate all the problem
formulation in a way that is uh aligned
with the definition of backwardable set
particularly because uh belonging to a
set or not is a binary condition while
in backwardable set sorry in the optimal
control formulation we only framed it in
terms of a cost function. So the
question is can we um
reframe
a membership to a set through the lens
of a cost function so that we can reduce
everything to the optimal control
formulation to which we can then apply
the HT Yakobi EOX equation
and the short answer is yes we can
encode this boolean outcome of belonging
or not to target set uh within the
Hamington Yakobi EAX formulation by
removing the running cost. Since we only
care about being in the target set at
the final time or not being in the final
set at the target time, there is no
notion of
running cost and by picking the final
cost to denote set membership.
The question is how we do that. Turns
out that this is relatively
easy and leads to the um
level set method for backward reachable
computations.
Specifically remember the uh equations
that one needs to solve in order to find
the optimal control profile in a
differential game.
In our problem, we only care about
getting into the backwardable set at the
final time. There is no notion of a
running cost. So accordingly, we set the
running cost G equal to zero for the
specific case of computing backward set.
So we are only left with the final cost
H which shows up in the boundary
condition for the partial differential
equation. Now can we pick a final cost
that reflects the notion that you either
belong to a target set or you do not
belong to the target set and the answer
is affirmative. So one can always find a
function h of x such that set t the
target set is equal to the zero cell
level set of h that is x
belong to a given set t if and only if h
of x is less than or equal to uh zero.
Let me give you an example and through
the example you see that this is
actually quite obvious. So let's assume
that the set capital T is represented by
a circle
with radius R.
So T is defined as
the set of point X such that
X² + Y²
is less than or equal to r.
Now you can define a function h that is
a function of so let's assume that the
state space of our system is three
dimensional. So we have a unic cycle
with state x the longitudinal position y
the lateral position and theta the
heading. So we can define the function
uh h as h of xr y r theta r
as
square root of
so
if your unicycle whose state space is
threedimensional xy position and heading
has a x y coordinates such that h is
negative. What is the unicycle?
We assume that uh
we have a reference frame like this one.
If the function h is less than equal to
zero, where is it?
>> Inside the circle.
>> Inside the circle. Exactly. Because it
means that the square the distance is
less than r. So if h
less than or equal to zero it means
x² + y^2 less than or equal to r which
means that its position its displacement
from the origin has to be less than r.
So it's inside the circle. If h is
greater than zero it means that you are
outside.
And of course the more h is negative
means the deeper you are in the circle
the more h is positive uh the farther
you are from the circle. So actually the
magnitude h also has a uh an
interpretation in terms of how safe or
how safe you are. But most importantly
uh the sub uh level set of h tells you
whether a system is in the target set or
is not in the target set.
So then the idea of uh reframing
backwardable set through the lens of
habit of economy is equation is fairly
straightforward. You remove the running
cost. This is not not running cost and
computing backwardable sets. You find a
function h that represents
uh belonging to a given set whatever for
whatever target set t you have defined
that's always possible. Of course, if
you have uh something that is a bit more
complicated than a circle, then a
function h is going to be a bit more
complicated, but that's not a problem.
And thus,
we have reframed the problem of uh
avoidance of a [snorts] target set as
the problem of uh maximizing over u. We
want to stay outside of the set. So we
want to make us as player one we want to
make H positive while the enemy player
two wants to make H H H H H H H H H H H
H H H H H H H H H H H H H H H H H H H H
H H H H H H H H H H negative and so we
are in the same exact formalism of the
HTO is problem but the difference is
that we only have the final cost we
don't have the running cost remember
that or the continuous time optimal
control formulation the final time is a
zero so we start from some negative time
and the final time is zero this is more
more of a convention.
So this is an example. So this is an
example where the avoidance set is this
red circle
for this trajectory here.
The cost is positive since the final
point is outside of the void set which
means that the h the final cost is
positive. And then uh opposite to that
for this blue trajectory the final
condition is in the circle which means
that h is negative which means that the
overall cost is negative.
So we're not doing anything deep here.
We're just trying to find a onetoone
correspondence between the abstract
problem of backward virtual set
computation and the tool that we know of
which is that of y.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So that's why actually the
magnitude of age not only allows you to
reflect the problem of reachable set
computation in the habit manda framework
but also gives you some interesting
additional information which is loosely
speaking a buffer information about how
much buffer you have before crossing the
danger line which is when h is equal to
zero. So short answer is yes.
Okay. So we're always they're almost
there. So this is the formulation for an
avoidance set. So now that you want to
uh so if you have a problem where you
want to find the backward reachable set
that is the set of initial conditions
that would lead you to a collision. So
for your state to enter some unsafe
region for some adversarial selection of
the two this profile. The problem that
you want to solve is minimax problem. We
already discussed how to pick h and then
there is nothing else that you have to
do. You just write down the ham
is equation for this specific problem.
Same as last time we don't have the
running cost. And of course for the
boundary condition we use the h function
that represents membership to a given
set.
If instead you want to solve the
opposite problem that of reaching a
goal. So now you want to enter into the
set. So you want to make H negative and
the player wants to make the natural
wants to make H positive because it
doesn't want you to go into the set.
Then the problem formulation is a swap
in terms of minimax. And now you want to
minimize H. Player two wants to maximize
uh the the cost. So all stays the same.
It's just that the max the max mean and
min max are swapped in the conditions.
So you do the same derivation but just
sweeping swapping max. Yeah
such that you can enter the testable set
like
a setible
set. [laughter and clears throat]
>> Yeah I mean there's a backward set but
by physical set what do you mean
exactly?
Of course.
>> Yeah, of course.
>> Become then your target set and then you
complicate dynamics even.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Of course. And in general,
we see
uh so I think your question is pointing
actually to the next point I want to
make here which is the following
that the formulination so far is pretty
static. So basically I'm telling you
what is the set of initial conditions
such that at the end you are in a
desirable condition but in general you
want to be desirable along your full
trajectory not necessarily just at the
end point
which leads to the notion of an
evolution of the concept of reachable
set into a reachable tube. Specifically
look at this case. So here we have a
case where trajectory stays outside of
the avoidant set
uh so the cost is positive. Here you
have
in particular because the end point is
outside. Here you have a blue trajectory
the end point is inside. So the cost is
negative. Okay. But here there is a case
whereby the trajectory passes through
the avoidance set for some time at t
less than zero. But then t equals z. So
at the end the state is outside of the
avoidance set. So the cost because of
how we formulated the problem before is
negative. So we deem this trajectory as
safe.
Well I mean it's safe for the end point
but [clears throat] there was a portion
of time where you were in the danger
zone. Maybe this is zone where you were
too close to another aircraft. So you
might have had an air miss.
So the question then is how do we make
sure that we protect the full trajectory
from being outside of an avoidance set
as opposed to just the end point. This
leads to the notion of a cube whereby we
want to reason not just with respect to
the final time but across the full
time horizon. So basically you're
building a safety tube so that you stay
you know your trajectory and basically
tube outside it outside of the abalon
set. Can we still use
techniques from eax equation? The answer
is yes we can. I will just give you the
intuition here because this gets a bit
more convoluted but essentially the
intuition is as follows. So before so in
the setting of reachable set you cared
only about the final end point.
Now you care about making sure that your
entire trajectory stays out of the
avoidance set. How do you change the
problem formulation such as such that
you encode this objective? So one way
that you could do that is by replacing h
of x0 as your cost with the minimum of
toao in the optimization horizon of h of
x to. So what this is saying is that you
are interested in making sure that not
just h evaluated at x of0 is greater
than zero which means that you're safe
but that the minimum of h across all of
that trajectory is greater than zero
because if that is the case it means
that at every single point in time h
evaluated at x of t is greater than zero
which means that you are outside of the
Make sense? So basically you are
strengthening or actually making your
cost a bit more sophisticated
to encode the notion that you don't just
care about what happens at the end of
the optimization horizon but you care
about what happens throughout the
horizon. In particular, you want to make
sure that
you in the worst possible situation
across your optimization horizon, H
never dips below zero.
Now, this is a cost that we haven't seen
last time. So, actually changes a little
bit the derivation that we did. We're
not going to do the derivation but
basically the ham is equation takes this
form that is a bit more complicated
because now we have an additional
minimization and I'm not going to dig
much deeper than that. My main point is
that uh if you care about making sure
that your entire trajectory stays out of
danger, there is actually a formulation
of optimal control that allows you to
compute that object is a limit of a
refinement of a yakobi isex equation. We
are not going to go down this path
because we have many other concepts to
discuss in this class. But if you're
interested, I provided you with the
references to do so. My most important
point here is to make sure that you are
familiar with this problem and you know
that there are tools at your disposal to
solve it.
>> Yeah.
>> So both the BR and BR like a set of
initial states.
>> Yeah.
>> So what is the different property? So
here you make sure that is a set of
initial states such that you don't end
up in danger at the uh end optimization
horizon. This is the set of of initial
states such that throughout the
optimization horizon you stay out of
danger.
Are we solving for either the VR or are
we solving
>> for two things? You're solving for the
VRS and you're solving for the optimal
control profile U.
So I mean you start from the uh from a
state in the backward set. Okay. But if
you don't use the optimal control
policy, you might still actually in the
case of the avoidance set, you start
with initial condition outside of the
backward set. But if you don't use the
optional control policy, actually the
disturbance might still lead you into
the avoidance set. So you need both both
the set and the associated optimal
control policy. But the optional control
policy once you have solved for the
harmonia is equation can be computed
quite readily. So this is a easy
computation.
So once you compute uh the
backward set, you can also easily
compute the optimal control.
>> Yeah.
>> So like what you were talking about with
reaching versus avoiding when you hear
you switch maximum to minmax in the
value function and the backwards
reachable two [clears throat] does the
outside.
>> So here are two things right. So there
is avoid versus reach and tube versus
set. So this slide is only about avoid
versus reach.
>> There is no notion of cube here.
>> Is there any notion of reaching for
tubes like if you want if you want your
agent to pass through a certain
corridor.
>> Yeah, there is even though it's less
commonly used. So typically
in even though I um frame the problem
also from the point of view of reach
typically reachability based
computations are used more for the
purposes of safety to basically is
additional constraints you have your
trajectory optimization process to make
sure that you have enough buffer uh to
avoid collisions or stuff like that. So
the most common fmination is the
avoidance safety one.
So let me show you one example. And of
course the set of initial conditions for
which you're guaranteed to stay out of
danger is that such that the value
function is uh
uh greater than zero.
Now let me show you an example to make
things these things a bit more concrete.
Yes. Oh, if our dynamics make it such
that we can never reach our target set,
what happens when you're trying to
initialize?
Yeah, basically your set is empty
and uh either you change a problem or
you don't control basically you don't
deploy your robot but at least it gives
you a strong information means that uh
at the way you frame a problem maybe
because you were too conservative it
might be that is too your problem
formulation is too conservative maybe
you don't have enough control actuation
so you want to spend a bit more money on
buying better actuators but is saying
something about your problem
formulation. Maybe it's just how you
find a problem or maybe there is an in
limitation in your robot your robot and
then
for example you have to design a better
robot have more control authority but
yeah so let me show one example. So this
is actually quite illustrative. So we
have a situation whereby we have two
airplanes model as um with unicycle
dynamics. So the equations of motion for
the first airplanes are x dot= v cos
theta y dot is equal v sin theta theta
dot is equal u. So essentially the state
space is three dimensional xy position
and heading and you control the heading
theta. So basically uh uh the time rate
of change of the heading through the
control u
and the vehicle goes at speed v.
Same equations of motion for the other
vehicle x dot= vin theta y dot= vin
theta t dot equ= u.
So now I pose you this question. So what
is the initial set of uh what is the set
of initial conditions joint? So between
aircraft A and aircraft B
such that there is a trajectory for
aircraft B that no matter how much we're
trying to avoid a collision might lead
it to a collision where by collision we
mean that the relative position between
A and B
is in
so the relative distance is less than R.
So essentially our avoidance set is
indeed a circle
in the relative uh position x a - xb and
y a minus yb. We want the relative
distance between the two aircraft to be
less than r. So if we center
everything around the aircraft A, we
want to make sure that B is never inside
this kind of own ship circle.
So what is the set of initial conditions
that allow us to make sure that a
collision or at least a near miss never
happens.
So we are exactly in the setting of
computing an avoidance set and
associated control profile for player A
that is us to avoid a collision.
So I posted a script.
Is the problem clear?
Any question about the problem set? I
mean this is a real stuff. I mean how
people may want to implement some level
of collision avoianance for aircraft.
So
I implemented
a haba copy reachability computation. So
this is useful because it gives you
reference code base to do this type of
computation.
But here in particular I want to show
the uh main result. So I implemented the
dynamics of uh these systems. Uh so this
is not too important but we just
highlight here
even though it's a bit small that
basically the the terminal set the
terminal values is defined as defined as
the circles with radius five. So that's
where I implement uh the h function.
So I call a package we cod it up in my
lab called hj reachibility. This is
essentially the end result of an HJ
computation. So what this thing saying
is a weird shape.
So X
represents in um relative coordinate the
relative longitudinal displacement.
So if this is aircraft
aircraft
so this distance here will be X
this distance here
will be Y.
So what we have here and Z is the
relative heading between the two
aircraft. Okay.
So this is the zero level set of the
cost function as computed through
kameobi is equation
which means that if for those set of
states for which j is negative
[snorts] namely you are within this
green uh uh shape
then you might end up in a collision if
you're outside you don't end up in a
condition what is weird shape So to
illustrate how to interpret this result.
So this is basically the set of states
for which J is equal to zero.
Assume that Z the relative heading
is um
this [clears throat] the heading is a
zero. So basically the aircraft are at
one
are aligned.
Well, so
if uh this is the case, then in order to
be out of danger, this is just the
aircraft can follow each other. Either
they start outside of the circle and
they will stay outside of the circle
forever, or if they are inside the
circle, we just stay inside the circle
forever and they are in a dangerous
situation. So that's why the um backward
reachable set has simply the shape of
your set.
But let's see what happens when Z the
relative heading is close to three which
basically means pi.
So it takes a little bit actually of
practice to view all of this but then it
becomes quite intriguing. I know why
it's not picking this up.
So this is the part where I had to show
my computer. It's very difficult to
show this shape uh on the board.
Yeah. So let me try to make it a bit
bigger.
So say that
told you that is a little bit tricky.
Come on.
So say that you are
pi = 3 so that the aircraft are opposite
of each other.
And
So this axis is still the longitudinal
displacement. So what is this saying
that if
you are with a positive longitudinal
displacement namely
the air so this aircraft A so aircraft B
is here in order to ensure
collision avoidance initially the
aircraft have to be more separated
because the other aircraft is just
pointing at you so you need a little bit
more maneuver in space in order to avoid
the aircraft. If instead that the
aircraft is beneath you, then no
problem. The only thing that you care
about is that you don't start in a
situation where you are already within
the circle. But then otherwise you can
just escape. So that's why you have this
kind of protrusion in this direction to
take into account about the geometric
uh part and dynamic part of the problem.
Does it make sense? So this is just
saying something obvious, right? that if
the two uh aircraft are on a collision
course, you need to have a more lateral
separation. That's what this uh blob
here is saying.
But it's kind of nice that we computed
actually from first principle and we
know exactly for then each possible uh
value of the relative heading by how
much you want to ensure lateral
separation also take into account
longitudinal separation also take into
account about lateral separation. So now
I can tell you exactly how much
longitudinal separation you should have
if if you start from this initial
condition or if you start from initial
condition. Of course this one from the
point of view avoiding collision is
worse than this one and this is actually
deflecting this kind of non-symmetrical
shape of this object. Yeah the same
constant velocity.
>> Yes. Yeah. Otherwise that you can also
choose two different velocities of
course the shape of the thing will
change
just to reiterate on the concept. So
here I'm showing how the um projection
of the backward reachable set it changes
depending on how long the time horizon
is. For now let's just look at the uh
black carb here. Blue means negative. I
mean darker blue means negative
everything else means positive. So here
is the scale.
So this is essentially the projection of
that weird thing that was three
dimensional
on a 2D space where we fix the relative
heading at 3.7. So be higher than pi x
still notion of longitudinal distance y
notion of lateral distance.
So we're fixing the relative heading at
a more than pi. So it's basically
something like that.
So the vehicle is pointing the vehicle B
is pointing this direction and then you
want to understand where it should be
placed at the beginning to make sure
that we do not in incur a collision. So
fix the longitudinal separation equal to
five.
So if and and my point is why basically
the reachable set has this shape that is
a bit tilted.
Well, if you fix the longitudinal
separation at five,
then
do you want to add more lateral buffer
if
the vehicle so we're fixing the the
longitudinal separation, right? So the
question is, do you want to add more
lateral safety buffer if the vehicle
starts with a negative lateral distance
or with a positive lateral distance? In
other words, do you think that this
situation is safer or this situation is
safer?
Who votes for option one?
Who votes for option two? Great. Happy
to fly with all of you. So yeah, of
course, because this guy in order to
really collide with us, we need to do a
much more complicated maneuver and we
have much more space to evade.
So that's why now the reachable set is
tilted. It's simply saying that uh if
you are in with you start with a
negative lateral distance, you need less
buffer with a positive distance, you
need more buffer, you need up to five uh
say meters.
What is saying? Why is [snorts] this
thing evolving through time? The shape
of the reachable set of course depends
on the initial time. So if you are
computing the backward reachable set
from the perspective of time equal 2
minus 2.5 - 3 - 3.5 remember that the
final time is always zero for these
computations.
So it turns out that after 3.5 units of
time actually the backward reachable set
goes to a constant. So after 4 -4 -5 - 6
you always get the same backwardable
set. Why is that the case is that in
most of these problems where things are
stationary after a transent then the
problem set ups into a stationary
situation whereby either the player two
is just chasing us or we have collided.
So it doesn't change that we have more
time at our disposal.
And let me show you some example of uh
so you do this computation you compute
the control profiles and then you start
injecting some possible initial
conditions. And here I picked three for
fun. So blue is player one red is player
two. So [clears throat]
we want to make sure that player two
doesn't enter our personal space.
[snorts] So here is situation where we
started in terms of relative coordinates
outside of the uh backwardable set. So
no matter how hard player two is try to
play the game to catch with us it can't
velocity here is the same. You see that
after a while then you just go into a
steady state. Additional time doesn't
really buy you anything.
So this is a situation where we started
with player two essentially inside the
personal space and then it just locks in
and then it stays in our personal space
throughout.
Here is an interesting case that I found
whereby
the um player two for a little while a
transition in our backward reachable set
sorry in our u protected space but then
we're able to maneuver out and then the
other player is unable to catch with us.
So for the way we frame this problem we
have succeeded.
In reality, we should care about the
fact that for some small portion of time
actually player two
enter our personal space. So this is
undesirable. So this motivation for
actually switching to backwardable tube
formulation which is not what we're
doing here. So that's why for this
computation actually this is success
story but in reality probably would like
to use a backwardable to formulation in
which case this will be a negative
story.
So what I'm doing here is just to
initialize the two vehicles inside or
outside the backward set playing the
game optimally as derived through the
solution the arbit is equation and then
displaying the trajectories.
Isn't this cool? I think it's nice
and people use this stuff for real. So
for example
um in the um uh in several production
grade autopilots for cars you have
something that is reminiscent of a
backward reachable set to ensure that at
the you know lowest level of safety no
matter what another driver might do
close to you uh you still have a safety
buffer so that you can maneuver around.
Yeah
to converge from
>> the backward tool. So first of all here
we're not computing backwardable to
>> we are computing backwardable sets in
general for a time bing formulation uh
it converges to a steady state solution.
I think it's pretty neat. I know that
mathematically probably this was the
most sophisticated lecture.
I tried to give you uh as much intuition
as I could. The treatment of
differential games mathematically
speaking is quite uh involved. Uh but I
do hope that at least you have an
understanding of the main ideas about
what is possible with this formalism and
also what are the underlying uh
algorithmic packages that allow you to
uh algorithm
concepts and packages that allow you to
solve these problems.
And speaking about algorithmic packages,
how do you solve this stuff? Well,
solving a partial differential equation
is hard. Uh actually
the example that I gave you is based on
a package we developed in my lab which
is one of the fastest packages written
in Python to solve harmonility
equations. So you could use that. That
said, typically
you can solve these problems for
maybe five dimensional state space, six
dimensional state space and then things
break down because of the car
dimensionality. So the solvers don't you
know don't don't scale beyond uh uh that
dimensionality. That said doesn't mean
that you can't solve problem with more
than five six dimensions. you just had
to resort to approximations and this is
still a fairly active field of research.
There are many different ways of
breaking the scalability barrier by
using approximations through neural
networks, sampling based methods, giving
up some guarantees of accuracy and so on
and so forth. So I won't go into the
details here but at least you have an
exact implementation of a ham
computations through the AJ package that
I show you before. And then uh just for
you to know there are a number of
techniques that are approximate in
nature that allow you to solve this
problem beyond five or six dimensions.
All right, let's move to MPC.
Any questions in the meantime
comparatively speaking MPC is going to
be a walk in the park in terms of
complexity.
NPC is actually very
It's very intuitive in general. It just
feels right. I think as a control
strategy as you would see
going back to road map. So we spend
quite a bit of time on openloop optimal
control. We spent quite a bit of time on
closed loop optimal control.
This is fast but less powerful because
you reason in terms of openloop control
sequences. This is uh powerful. You
reason in terms of closed loop policies
but computationally complex both in the
discrete time formulations through the
discrete time Bman equation or in the
continuous time formulations through
Kobe Bman and Kobe EX. Can we get the
best of both worlds? Basically the speed
of an openloop control method with the
power
of a closed loop control methodology.
The answer is yes to a large extent
through the lens of MPC model data
control. MPC is really a framework more
than you know a specific uh control
strategy. That said, I would say that
after P controllers is probably the most
widely used control methodology out
there. Originally developed in the 70s
and 80s more as a theoristic promoted in
the chemical engineering domain. You may
wonder why chemical engineering because
um oh two reasons were first there was a
need you want to reason about
constraints typically in chemical
engineering you don't want the
temperature of the products that you're
mixing to go out of whack. Uh so you
really care about constraints otherwise
the entire thing blows up and
constraints are difficult to be dealt
with directly in through frequency based
controls. But at the same time, chemical
processes typically evolve on a slower
time scale, multiple seconds. So even
though MPC relies on often times online
optimization and at the time the
computers were not particularly fast,
people could still solve those
optimization problems at a level of you
know a few seconds. So it was just a
sweet spot. there was a need and
actually the problem itself was well
attuned to solve optimization problems
at maybe 0.5 htz or 0.1 hertz.
So what we're going to do today is to
introduce the basic ideas behind MPC and
start developing a bit of theory about
how to apply MPC
in a principal way. Good re readings
about MPC are the textbooks from Borelli
Bur Morari and the textbook from Rings
and Maine and Teal. These scientists in
general
um I mean quite influential in setting
up the algorithmic foundations of MPC.
Until the early 90s, MPC was used mostly
in noistic and then people in the 90s
and 2000s uh started developing a theory
about MPC that allow um researchers and
developers to deploy MPC with
mathematical
assurances about the correctness of the
design.
Most recently um as you know there have
been a lot of advantages in terms
advances in terms of online solvers. So
that has been the main trend to really
push MPC into the control loop with
increasingly most more stringent
requirements in terms of replanning
rates 10 herz 30 Hz kilohz and so on and
so forth.
So what is MPC? The idea of MPC is
really really simple and as I said very
natural.
So you the underlying idea is that you
have an infinite horizon optimal control
problem and you want to solve it
optimally.
Uh
but that is very expensive and so you're
fine with solving it suboptimally but
still in closed loop form.
So what does MPC do? MPC
measures and keeps basically track of
previous values of uh the states.
Based on that information based on
information about uh the dynamics based
on the controlling state constraints it
computes
a control profile. Here we assume that
we are solving the problem in discrete
time. So essentially solves a d it
solves um an openloop optimal control
problem over a finite horizon between
time t at time t + n p.
You find your openloop control sequence
along with a predicted sequence of
states or outputs
that stem from the application of your
optimized control sequence
to dynamics of your system.
So, so far this is just a openloop
optimal control.
But then what MPC does is to use only
the first control
that makes the system transition to the
new state or output at time t + one. And
then you completely discard everything
else that you computed at the previous
planning cycle. And you recomputee
everything from scratch. But now
starting at a new state at time t plus
one.
with the idea that at every single
planning cycle you always compute you
always solve for an openloop control
problem.
But since you replan which means that
you get to observe a new state and based
on that you solve a new openloop optimal
control problem. you actually
um
endow the entire framework with a notion
of closed loop because you are closing a
loop on your most recent observation of
the state.
But you're always solving openloop
control problem. Turns out that is
really a sweet spot between doing open
loop optional control and actually using
close loop information from the
measurement of the state.
It seems wasteful, right? because you
solve the problem over maybe a long
horizon and then everything that you
have computed after the first time step
goes into the trash.
Not always because you can always use
this information to inform the solution
at the next step. But in its simple
simplest vanilla form, you put
everything into the trash. There are
some nuances like for example you may
want to compute your uh optimal control
sequences up until horizon t plus n and
m but keep your predictions going for a
little bit further. So there are there
are a lot of variations in the team. So
NPC is a framework. It's not a specific
control algorithm. But the main idea is
that you do um resting horizon
optimization always moving which again
is very natural is also what we do as uh
humans. We optimize our control profile
then we walk around a little bit. Of
course we gather information and we
revise our plan. So the idea shouldn't
be too surprising.
Does it make sense?
There is a little bit of notation here t
+ 1 plus k given t1 t + one. I will
explain this terminology in a sec.
So cadious at each sampling time t we
solve an openloop optimal control
problem over a finite horizon. How long
the horizon should be we will discuss in
later. [snorts]
We apply the optimal input signal during
the the sampling interval t+1.
We throw into the trash everything else.
Then the system under the application of
this input evolves into the new state at
time t plus one. And now at time step
t+1 we solve a new optimal control
problem based on new measurements of the
state of a shifted horizon. So now the
horizon goes one step into the future.
So let me give you a little bit more
concrete formulation.
particular in the setting
of linear dynamics. So we consider the
problem again of regulating to the
origin uh the discrete time linear time
environment system xt + 1 equal ax plus
bu. So very similar to what you would do
with classical frequency domain control
but we also have constraints. So this is
not something that you can do with
classical frequency based control. So we
assume that the state X belongs to some
capital set X. So the set of safe states
and U belongs to some capital set U. And
here we're assuming that the sets X and
and U are polyhedra. That is that are
sets that can be defined by finitely
many linear inequalities. So basically
half planes that defines your physible
state space.
a cube for example you're confined
within a cube
so what is the basic formulation of MPC
then assume that
we can measure fully the state x of t
then at each replening time at t we
solve an optimal control problem in open
loop in terms of the variables ut + one
all the way to ut plus n minus one to
minimize an additive cost but now you
should be very familiar with the
structure. So you have a terminal cost
plus the summation of a running cost
subject to the dynamics state
constraints control constraints. The
initial condition has to be XD the state
you are in right now. That's how you
close the loop. And also potentially
adding some terminal constraint. So you
want to make sure that your predicted
state after n steps belong to some
desirable uh set x of f. I will discuss
later why we may want to add this
constraint.
So you solve for this optimal control
sequence. You use the first term, you
move into state XD + one, you measure it
and then you reply.
Where is all this complicated
formulation here coming from? You know,
yes. So this vertical bar T and so on.
What does that mean?
So that means the following. So xt + k
given t
just terminology is the state vector at
time t + k predicted at time t via the
system dynamics. U + k given t is the
input u at time t plus k computed at
time t. Note that the state predicted a
step three from the perspective of time
one is not necessarily the same state
three predicted from the perspective of
time two simply because maybe
disturbance might have perturbed our
nominal trajectory.
Any questions here?
So here what I want to highlight is
these two guys.
So these two guys are
additional terms that we inject in our
MPC formulation
to regularize it.
You know the our optimal control
formulation
basically has the running cost. It has
the control constraints. where are this
determinal constraint coming from and
where is this
this auxiliary cost that is placed on
the predicted variable app and coming
from. So those two terms are actually
the two designing choices or tuning
knobs that as MPC designers you can tune
in order to optimize the performance of
an MPC an NPC uh control framework. So
what we will see for the rest of this
lecture and then the lecture on
Wednesday will be to see how do we
tune
this auxiliary terminal constraint here
these uh terminal cost here and
potentially the pen. So how much look
ahead steps you have to make sure that
you uh have a good formulation a good uh
performance once you deploy MPC and in
general you care about two things first
of all you care about the so-cal notion
of a persistent physibility so you want
to make sure that once you transition
into the new state the new optimal
control problem that you're trying to
solve is still feasible otherwise you're
stuck I mean that's back to your
colleagues equation before. What happens
when the reachable set for example is
empty? You don't want to end up in that
situation because it means that you're
stuck. You have nothing that you can do.
Whatever you do basically you're going
to violate a constraint. So how do you
make sure that that doesn't happen. So
how do you play with your tuning knobs
so that that doesn't happen? And then of
course assuming that that doesn't happen
how do you make sure that you fulfill
your task in this case regulating the
state
to the origin. So you basically want x
equal to zero.
Okay. So we talked about the terminology
before we address the two equations I
mentioned before. Let me add a little
bit more notation but not too much. So
uh as I said what you do in MPC is you
take the first control in your in the
optimal control sequence that you have
computed
which is a function of the state because
the first predicted state has to be
equal to the current state X of T of
course
and that's the control that uh you enact
on your system.
Then the optimization problem is
repeated at time t + one but with a new
state constraint that the state
predicted at time t + one from the
perspective t+1 has to be the state at
time t+1 as measured.
So now we can define a closed loop
policy
as the first control input that is
determined when we solve the optimal
control problem starting from the state
x of t. You see how actually this is how
we are closing the loop and bridging the
gap between closed loop control
sorry and the open loop optional
control. Is this point clear? That's a
bit the cracks of MPC.
So then the closed loop evolves as x +
1= ax + b pi which we can abstractly
written as a closed loop function of x
and the time.
So how do we characterize the crucial
behavior of the system?
One more thing notationally and I know
this is a bit boring but uh we need
later is that in the case that the
problem is time involving that is a does
not explicitly depend on the current
time. So there is no subscript a k b
does not depend on the current time c
does not depend on the current time.
So this problem the only thing that
changes across planning horizon is the
initial condition for the state. So
we can write it in a simpler form where
we drop all the thing of uh uh
predicting from perspective time t and
so on and so forth. We can just drop all
that terminology and use this simpler uh
formulation. But with understanding that
we solve this problem starting a state x
of t we use the first control u0 we
transition into a new state xt plus one
and then we saw the same problem but now
with x0 equal xt + one yeah
you have some
>> oh sorry so does this formulation
require that our uh like time horizon is
long enough for the vinyl that stay at
time n or
>> yeah otherwise you may not get there yes
yeah I
Uh in general
the best way to see MPC is that the um
underlying problem you're trying to
solve is on infinite horizon which as we
discussed before is bit of an
abstraction of course was a good
framing.
>> Does that
uh
make it so if you shorter you might have
more aggressive control.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So and actually if it's too short
you may not actually converge and
regulate your state. So that's why the
time horizon the terminal cost
P and the terminal constraint X of F are
crucial to tune to make sure that you
properly balance
um look ahead capability. So how long in
the future you optimize over which is in
general the longer the better. you make
your decision more informed but you pay
more competition cost
and how short your term is in which case
you might be too greedy or even myopic
in which case you may not fulfill your
task. So it's going to be a delicate
balance between how much computation
time you want to invest versus uh
whether you can actually achieve your
task.
Okay, so in a simplified notation then
your optimal control is the first
control input that you compute in the
previous optional control formulation
and then you have a closed loop control
law.
Now with what type of cost functions do
people use here not many surprises.
So for the running cost quite common to
use just a quadratic cost similar to LQR
or you might use also some other uh P
norms where for example you could use
the one norm or the infinity norm
one norm of a vector
uh I don't have a marker
A
is the sum of the absolute value of it
component
instead of the square.
Um
so to wrap wrap it up to in online
modity control we measure the state x of
t we solve finite time optical control
problem if god forbid
the problem is invisible you're stuck
you call for help otherwise you apply
the first element u zero to the system
you transition to the new time t + one
you measure xt + one and you repeat. Why
online? Because here the idea is that we
are solving this problem online. So as
you are deploying your system as we will
discuss briefly next time there are also
offline formulation whereby you do the
optimization offline basically
anticipating all possible conditions
that might arise.
But for most of these exposition of MPC
we will consider only the online
version.
Right. So what I was what I was [snorts]
mentioning before is that what are the
things we care about? So
the two things we care about are
persistent physibility
and stability. Persistent physibility we
want to make sure that uh the optimal
control problem is always feasible.
[snorts] That's quite obvious.
Stability means that uh
uh we want to make sure that the genetic
control inputs
lead to trajectories that converge to
the origin. So the question is how do we
tune the three main designs so that
these two objectives are fulfilled.
Up until the 90s this was mostly
holistic. Then between the 90s and 2000
that's where people started putting some
theory to allow you to make informed
choices about how to select those
students.
So sorry for the cough.
That's what we're going to discuss next.
So there are two possible way of
approaching a problem. The first one
is a closed loop system, right? So we
have xt + one
equal
f of a closed loop x of t.
We try to somewhat analyze how the
dynamics of this closed loop system
evolve depending on the three tuning
knobs and then we optimize the three
tuning knobs. That's very hard because
this is a nonlinear system that entail
an inner optimization. So this closed
loop function f is b the result of
applying an optimization step. So it's
difficult to analyze and that's where
the people were stuck.
Then people realize that a better way to
do that is to directly derive conditions
and the terminal function P the terminal
constraint set XF so that the persistent
physibility closibility are guaranteed
by design without having to analyze ad
hoc the uh uh trajectory evolutions.
So what we're going to do next is to
first tackle the problem of persistent
physibility. That's the most basic one
basic one. If you can even solve the
optimal control problem then the
question of stability is not even really
matter and then we're going to see how
we can once we solve the problem
persistent physibility address the
problem of stability.
So let's focus on persistent physibility
first. So the goal is to tune our tuning
knob so that physibility for all future
times is guaranteed.
To test the problem we leverage tools
from invarance theory. So I'm going to
give you a little bit more terminology.
Sorry about that. Um, MPC is a little
bit less mathematically intense than um,
reachability, but it's a bit more boring
in terms of terminology.
What is an invariant set? So, let me
first pin down a little bit of
terminology. So we define the set of
physible initial state capital X0 as the
set of states
that are physible meaning belong to the
set capital X such that there is a
physible
control sequence by physical feasible
mean that each control UK belongs to
capital U
such that the evolution of the state
trajectories stemming from the
application of this control sequence
gives gives rise to states that are
visible at all times and such that the
terminal state belongs to the desire to
the desired final set.
So this is a set of initial conditions
for which the optimal control problem
has at least one solution.
A control input can be found only if our
current state belongs to this set.
Then we define a notion of a
controllable set
for an autonomous systems xt + 1 = 5 of
x of t with a state and control
constraints. The onestep controllable
set to set s is defined as the set of
states such that after one step
application of our transition dynamics
we end up into set s.
Yes. Great. Thank you.
Specifically
say that uh you're given a set
S.
The question that you are asking is what
is the set of states referred to as
P R E or previous of S
such that if you start here
and then you apply your dynamics f ofx
you end up here.
So you're given a set you're trying to
answer the question what is the set of
state such that after one step under the
natural dynamics of the system I learn
into S.
The notion of a one step controllable
set extends to the case of a control
system where now X + one is a function
of X and U where the definition is very
similar. The only difference is that now
we define the onestep controllable set
as the set of states for which there
exist a u such that a onestep
application of our dynamics leads us
into s.
So there exist a u such that f of xu
leads me into s in one step. Well that's
just a definition.
One more set of definitions. So
another important uh definition is the
notion of a control invariant set.
Actually this is a concept that arises
quite ubiquitously in model predictive
control.
A given set C is a control environment
set.
Let's call it DC. A given set C is a
control environment set for a given
system XT + 1= F of XU.
If
if you start in C, so this is your state
X of T,
then there exist a control U such that
under the state transition dynamics, you
land in C. So if you start in C, think
of C say as the safe set, the set of
related states where you are far enough
from danger, there exists a U that
allows you to stay in that set, which
seems a usable, a useful concept.
So there exist a U
such that f of x u
lands into again c the same set.
So of course you want to choose the C as
a set of desirable states. [snorts]
The sets C infinity this is really just
a minor notation is set to be the
maximum control environment set if this
control environment and contains all
control environment sets containing X is
basically the largest possible control
environment set that you might have for
a dynamical system.
Similar definition arises for autonomous
systems. So systems where you don't have
explicit dependence on the control a set
is set to be positive invariant if
after one application of the uh so if
you start in uh the set A and you apply
your dynamics you still remain in A.
So these sets can be computed by using a
fairly powerful MATLAB tool called MPT
and actually you would use this tool as
part of your homework. Yeah.
how control it could not be maximal
but an example said
>> yeah I mean sure I mean you might have a
controlling set with this definition but
no one is telling us that there might
not be like an extension
that still has this property so actually
you must so for example a control
environment set could be zero for I mean
literally the set with a single point
zero whereby if you have a linear system
and you start a state equals zero and
use control u equals 0 the next state is
zero
so the origin typically you see what I'm
saying you start at the origin x= 0
assuming that the control u is a
physible control then i ax plus b u is
still zero which means the next state is
zero so that's a control set but that
doesn't mean that there might be some
other states that actually still allow
you to transition into uh the same set.
We'll see actually some examples later.
All right. So let's get to the first
useful result related to physibility
which is as follows. So let's define X1
as the truncated physibility set. So the
set of uh states for which the problem
now solve over an horizon n minus one is
feasible. So this is the set of states
such that there exists a truncated
control sequence starting from U1 and
not U0
such that uh it it is feasible that UK
belongs to U and so that under
application dynamics the states satisfy
the state constraints and satisfy the
terminal constraint.
Key result is as follows. If set X1 is a
control environment set
for your system then the MPC low is
persistently visible.
The intuition is that basically if X1 is
control invariant you can use this
control environment to buy one step of
staying in that set and then solve the
problem for n minus one steps.
Now the result per se I mean we'll prove
this result next time. The result per se
is completely useless because your
tuning knobs are XF
are the terminal cost P and are the
horizon N. You don't really control the
you don't really tune X1. But as we will
see this is a useful lema that allow us
to then derive a theorem that is
actually actionable allows us to tune
the tuning ups that we have in MPC. So
we'll prove this lema next time we take
uh five 10 minutes at most and then we
continue our exposition about persistent
physibility and then we move into uh
stability. The end result will be a set
of conditions that tells you explicitly
how to tune a PN and a terminal set X of
F uh to ensure persistent physibility
and stability. And then in your P set
you will solve a few problems so that
you really you know appreciate um this
theory. All right.
Okay.